I just want to say I am thrilled to be
your new captain I want this to be an
efficient ship but also one that you're
glad to be serving on lieutenant
commander Bordas your entire species is
male isn't it that is correct sir
probably not a lot of arguments about
leaving the toilet seat up and that kind
of thing or Buckland's urinate only once
per year really that's I mean I'm up to
three times a night that is unfortunate
it is see Orville premieres Sunday
September 10th on Fox head have a seat I
have good news there's a ship available
the USS or belt ever since I was a kid I
have wanted to serve on an exploratory
vessel you're nobody's first choice for
this job but we have 3,000 ships to
stand and we need captains and I want
his mince those are marvels we're giving
you one last chance I just want to say I
am thrilled to be your new captain I
want this to be an efficient ship but
also one that you're glad to be serving
on lieutenant commander boardís your
entire species is male isn't that is
correct sir
probably not a lot of arguments about
leaving the toilet seat up and that kind
of thing or Buckland's urinate only once
per year really that's I mean I'm up to
three times a night that is unfortunate
it is I'm gonna meet the locals hi I'm
captain ed nurses holy crap thank you we
don't mean your family any harm what we
did to shoot his dad aside from shooting
your dad we don't mean your family any
harm captain there's a message coming in
from Admiral Halsey it says that an
executive officer has become available
no no no no no no no no no no oh sorry
man you okay yeah it's all good man you
okay y'all good sorry all right no
worries the captain does not appear to
be pleased and here Rhonda with his
first officer they were married no way
you know how many times I tried to talk
to you before here
I would want to suggest a couple
therapist was your brother-in-law it
should be really fun trip for all of us
perhaps we should not be talking about
this oh no no we're talking about that
this is a thing you'll be delivering
supplies to the science station on
epsilon 2 thank you for coming we need
protection protection from what the
trill we have figured out a way to
manipulate the speed of events so it's
an anti banana ray it's really
interesting we need no longer fear the
banana does it work on offers we're
about to sell it you do realize this
could be used as a weapon that's why
you're here what is the captain Murphy
just detected a krill destroyer entering
orbit
your students flora don't open this jar
of pickles for me I loosened it for you
return fire give me the device or it
will destroying your ship sorry can you
can move like two steps to your right
it's just a lot of dead space there just
perfect gasps are you were just very
weirdly frame Oh what is that a beer
damn nervous you know it's a new ship
want to make a good impression it's 9:15
in the morning sorry
[Music]
you